okay first maybe let's do like a
collective hiss yes together something
very like this are all got a rock get
everything out that's in ready on the
count of three you have to do this with
me and who do you have to impress you
plant here we go
one two three yeah okay there was
something lovely about that also if you
were curious about my deleted scene from
the movie cats No
hi my name is Grace something dude no no
you know your life is different now oh
boy me you this that and also appreciate
you I appreciate me appreciate this
appreciate that you gotta have a mix you
gotta have the balance how are you doing
who knew that this would truly become
the motto of 2020
I didn't or did I no I didn't because I
don't know so many layers Oh also I've
been watching West world which isn't the
right time to watch West world a loose
fit of reality that I'm like kind of
desperately clinging on to who west
world likes to take that and go get off
get off get off
grace good luck tumbling down I've been
feeling all of the feelings as I'm sure
you've been feeling all of the feelings
yesterday I had a little cry to myself
in the bathroom which was nice to let
myself do that I moved a rug from this
room into the bedroom and it's really
just that was major that was huge I
can't stop looking at it in the bedroom
and looks and great you guys I don't
want to toot my own horn but two two two
two two two two
yeah that looked like me grabbing sky
dicks and I don't care Oh everything's
fine all doing the best we can I hope
cool kind of think about
fact that nothing's cool right now is
that we're all in it together that's the
one thing I keep forgetting about this
because when ISIL ate a lot of times I
really love to nicely I feel like really
alone then I get so caught up in that
world of thinking like I'm the only one
experiencing this and then as soon as I
do look around and see all the houses
that have people in it that are also
going through the same total spectrum of
emotions and see people walking on the
street also just trying to find some
semblance of sanity and see all the
people on Instagram doing their lives
lots of trying to find some sanity and
makes me at least feel a little better
that yeah we're all we're all just all
in it there's something beautiful about
that I haven't fully processed or
accepted that that beautiful yet but I
the brain gets it the heart has it fully
it's making its way down I also got a
new deep conditioner but then I put in
my hair because this [ __ ] only showers
like once a week I could tell Elliot
sometimes it's like when was last time
you showered I don't read books but I
can read between lines
I got a deep conditioner so that my hair
would be conditioned in the minimal
amount of showers that I take and it's
kind of greasy yeah this is what it is
and then just like feelings we map them
all down so that they're accepted and
appropriate for other people I went on
Instagram yesterday and I asked you guys
tell me just what's going on with you
and I'm just gonna go through some of
the things that caught my attention and
we'll see what happens because again
just in the feeling of we're all in this
together
let's go through your shoot are you
gonna do it's nothing you can do this is
a runaway train and I'm the only
passenger because I didn't let you on
because of social distancing and none of
you are wearing your masks we're get god
damn mats we're asked to do simple
little things just do it you think you
look like an idiot you look like an
idiot without it wow did ice cream grab
a lot of them okay y'all said some nasty
curious stuff what would you say
the dumbest way to decorate a bathroom I
think the dumbest way to decorate a bath
there would be maybe decorate it like a
kitchen fake fridge fake dishwasher fake
sink and then have like the stove feed
the toilet sit on the stove to pee how
much of a mind would that be my
boyfriend of two years and I are going
to different colleges what should we do
stay or break up I mean you should break
up yeah a whole life ahead of you and
this one that might not be the one it's
pretty early in your life for the one
and all so what a perfect time to test
out a breakup if you guys can't be
together right now start the break-up
now and all of this lifts and you guys
can hang out with other people like you
already have moved past the grieving
process you'll have done the cry in bed
watching Netflix because guess what
that's what we're all doing right now
even if we're not going through a
breakup the universe is presenting you
on a silver platter like here's the
environment that you are forced to be in
which is gonna simulate like being in a
breakup anyway so may as well just like
cut the cord oh maybe this is great
advice caveat none of this is probably
great advice anyone that's teacher I'm
gonna break up just do it right now
because the only option you have is
staying at home watching TV which would
be what you would do in a breakup but
everyone's doing it so you're not
missing out on social gathering but
through all your post breakup grieving
processes right now oh look at this gift
what a perfect time to explore your pain
my friend owes me money she also follows
you how do I ask her for payments if you
are watching right now and you owe a
friend money give it give them the money
also sorry this weird shadow is here the
Sun so deal with it I don't mean to add
extra anxiety into your already very
sensitive world what if I do that is
that better
would you prefer this I drank some
laxative tea
my constipation and now I wish I could
hold something in wow that is um that's
a real Greek tragedy also humblebrag be
good to your butthole it's part of your
body and everything it's all the parts
of your body are going through a lot
right now
your butthole it's maybe just giving you
a very symbolic expression of the way
you're feeling overall I don't know
diapers or an oven toilet those are my
only options how to make the birthday
any good when I'm locked down in the UK
we can't leave the house is this kind of
the best time to have a birthday party
because think clearly about like what do
you want from a birthday celebration
gonna hang out with your friends you can
do that over zoom do you want to get
drunk you can do that by yourself in
your home with that you also have the
power to already be in your home when
you hang out with your friends and get
drunk over zoom you're already in your
safe space you're already in your bed to
me this is like the greatest time to
have a birthday should i expedite my
birthday by six months and celebrate
like now oh just teaching kindergarten
online it's as awful as it sounds my
dear gosh they're doing that they're
having kindergarten over the Internet
that sounds like a pure punishment for
everyone involved uh how do you do what
I mean you may as well line up like a
bag of potatoes and see if you could
teach them the alphabet you need some
advice if you're teaching it over some
sort of like video chat sing with all
the kindergarteners who are video
chatting with you which in my mind is a
hilarious image maybe I love the fact
that that's happening now how do you
give a child a time out on the Internet
you just close their lebackes
okay maybe I'm really loving this well
good luck to you I'm making a train set
with my
my brother and it's going really well so
far are you one of the kindergarten
students from that woman's class that
sounds fun you're making a train set
with your dad and your brother that's
really sweet also I'm really glad that
this quarantine has made some of us live
like we're in the 1950s I'm entering the
year of quarter life crisis in
quarantine today any suggestions on how
to celebrate happy birthday I think is
what that means again a perfect time to
celebrate quarter life crisis while
everyone's already in crisis you're not
sticking out like a sore thumb you're
really just like in the majority maybe
the craziest thing would be to have a
quarter live content yes that means how
to celebrate I mean just let yourself go
wild six to ten feet away from every
other human being I suggest putting on
this song and just like letting the good
times roll
[Music]
working from home and my boss is still a
jerk I'd say nah whatever damn I gotta
get an extra six feet away from you
because you got a big old set of balls
fun thing to do if you do a video
conference for meetings or whatever it's
just to give tiny little middle fingers
right out of frame they'll never know
and there's something very dumb and very
fun about it like look this looks like
I'm just sitting here talking to you
guys I had a great time connecting with
my internet friends that are also
experiencing the same emotional spectrum
highs and lows that I'm experiencing now
I was doing this the whole time but
don't do that part just do the beginning
part how can I help my brother and my
mom were quarantined together and not
getting along I have a perfect plan for
you you have to be crazy you have to
start acting in ways that are bizarre
not harmful unpredictable not aggressive
and just confusingly strange walk around
talking on a pickle brush your teeth
with the remote control sleep next to
your bed completely harmless but they're
so confusing that hopefully it forces
them to come together to talk about you
and their concern for your well-being
you have a chance to be a real hero you
guys have ideas for other harmless
activities that this person can partake
in please leave them in the comments
below also I just need ideas to fill my
day Oh
organize the refrigerator mom's will
freak out about that refer to them as
big boy big girl know what to call your
mom big girl
what's your make up for lunch big girl
that's a great one do that and give back
to me and tell me how it goes this thing
to pile it on cause it's amazing thank
you so much and I haven't told you guys
on this channel yet but one of the
activities that I've been partaking in
quarantine because there's just not
enough of it in the world I starting a
new podcast with Elliott Morgan my
boyfriend we started a podcast called
pilot on it's all about our opinions
thoughts theories about reality
television that we watched specifically
right now we're talking very in-depth ly
possibly too in-depth ly about married
at first sight if you watch that show on
lifetime I'm obsessed I got Elliott into
watching it and we dissect it on a
weekly basis and this was a science
class I'd probably get kicked out for
dissecting too hard
over on his YouTube channel I'll link it
down below and we're trying to post it
every Friday there's more
blah-blah-blah-blah for you to enjoy
going to try to make a two year olds
birthday party special condoms can be
ballooned right absolutely also you can
tape a wick to the top of a dildo and
you got a birthday candle run with this
theme how to deal with not having
anything to look forward to it's super
depressing me and there's plenty to look
forward to right here right now there's
a video this is fun and delightful when
this is over you can go listen to pilot
on podcast you can go listen to this
might get weird podcast that memory
night do you can go listen to not too
deep look at all that to look forward to
and then after that I don't know put a
dildo in a children's birthday cake I'm
still working at a grocery store and
most people are rude with attitudes any
advice that sucks what you're doing is
awesome and to you for continuing to
work at the grocery store fun thing you
can do is get a box of condoms or
hemorrhoid cream from the shelf and keep
it by a register and when someone's
being a piece of [ __ ] to you right
before they're about to take their bags
go I'm sorry ma'am ma'am was this your
hemorrhoid cream it's not are you sure
not your hemorrhoid so you have
hemorrhoid condoms for these your
condoms a hemorrhoid cream and the
condoms are not yours weird okay you
have a great day wait for barging here
in Texas and I bought beer and ice cream
at the store so okay here's a science
project mix the beer with the ice cream
you'll have some kind of eruption what
to do when we run out of Florence wait
slice toilet paper well I hope you're
not wiping your [ __ ] with Clorox boy
I think there's other things that you
can use literally anything can be toilet
paper if you try to wipe your ass with
it in the style of Marie Kondo look
around your house and say will this
bring my [ __ ] joy and then you know
make your [ __ ] joyous trying to do
theater classes online just say
would be an understatement you're doing
theater classes online oh wow hey you
guys sound just like playing zip zap zop
/ zoom there's a group of people out
there that are doing that and Wow oh
that gives me tire King level anxiety
good for them that's cute oh here's an
idea why don't you in that kindergarten
class get together for one lesson and
have all of your theater students try to
mimic the kindergarteners isn't there a
lot of mirroring exercises and [ __ ] that
you guys are doing that would be oh I
don't want to be there to see any of it
but I think that would be beneficial for
all of you there's so much hopelessness
it's hard to deal with day in and day
out I know I know
doesn't it suck that we all feel so
hopeless and helpless it's stressful and
like you have no control over anything
you are really a bit of a speck of dust
in this giant sandbox but I think it's
okay to feel those things because to
push them away it would be repression
and that doesn't manifest itself well
and to think a little smaller about the
things you can do the small things that
you can do to start providing new
feelings for yourself what's something
that brings you joy is it watching TV is
it cooking something is it playing a
Wheel of Fortune game that you
downloaded on your phone and now you
play upwards of like three to four hours
a day on and have given way too much
money to this game app for what you're
not gonna win money from it you're never
going to win like the game is never
gonna give you money we keep giving the
game money so you can win diamonds
diamonds what are you doing with
diamonds it's not it's like what I don't
know how to help you I hope that maybe
something here eases some of the
hopelessness and reminds you that we're
all feeling and we're all experiencing
this and we all go through different
peaks and valleys and levels and pushes
and pulls of all these feelings that are
just floating all around our chaos
states and then it's okay it's good to
connect I know for me I didn't want to
like sit and make a video because I felt
like what's the [ __ ] point of making
stupid
videos but I like talking to you guys
and I like having a moment
to feel like this trivial trite stuff is
relieving that there's something
worthwhile in the dumb it's hard to let
myself like really embrace that but I'm
trying and I want to make more videos
possibly like this I think would be
necessary and fun right now to keep
connecting with you guys every week and
just like oh and just think about like
where's the most curious place I can put
a dildo for my boyfriend to find
tomorrow morning that's where I'm at
mentally I'm gonna put it in a box of
cereal alright this video is now getting
a little long-winded but this was really
fun and I needed this as much as you
might have needed this so keep badgering
me to do this in the future because it
takes me a second to get into the mode
of shooting and then once I'm here I'm
having a great time having a great time
you guys like this video give it a
thumbs up and I'll try to make another
one next week
and I hope you're doing as well as you
can and it's okay if you're not because
guess what I don't know